virtually every building here has been
affected in some way and if I could show
360 degree circle around here which I
can't because the signal is not strong
enough but there are damaged buildings
all around me behind me was an
eight-story Residential Building there
are just a few volunteers who are trying
to use pickaxes and their bare hands to
take out a rubble and being told that
you can actually see if we can try we'll
try and tentatively turn around here
because on this other building here
they're hearing voices as well
um and they they try every now and again
they tell us to be quiet so that they
can use their small drills that's all
they've got to try and drill down
there's people shouting on the top of
that building
they've already taken out at least four
corpses this morning and they're
shouting now saying that they've heard
people beneath a lot of people in this
province feel that they have been
forgotten that they haven't received
help that they're still not getting help
we saw crowds of people looting one of
the supermarkets saying that they were
hungry they had nowhere to stay no homes
no food and crucially no help at the
moment we understand that the main
government hospital here has been
deserted of medical staff it's partially
a destroyed infrastructure has been has
been affected badly there are still
patients in there some of them have been
killed by the earthquakes others have
died because they haven't been looked
after in the interim since the
earthquake this area is still very
vulnerable to aftershocks and further
earthquakes and there have been multiple
throughout the whole of the the turkey
Syria region